Willkommen zu einer neuen Folge von Fellow Cast.
Es ist wieder ein Video über den Moralpsychologie-
Workshop, den wir gestern hier in München hatten. Können
Sie uns sagen, wer Sie sind? Natürlich.
Ja,
danke für die Einladung. Mein Name ist
Gabriela Panini und ich bin
Postdoktorandin  an der University of Oxford
und ich arbeite zwischen der Abteilung für
Psychiatrie und dem Welcome Centre für
Ethik und Geisteswissenschaften. Okay, nett,
danke, und was ist das Gebiet Ihrer
Forschung, ein Kerngebiet? Ja, ich arbeite in der
Moralpsychologie und ich arbeite auch in der
angewandten Ethik  Daher denke ich, dass es für den
Zweck dieser Gruppe
interessanter ist, dass ich über die
Moralpsychologie in meiner Arbeit spreche. Ja, wenn Sie
möchten, ja, ja, an der Front der Moralpsychologie ist
im Moment meine neueste Arbeit,
die gerade in ein paar Jahren erscheint  Wochen
hat mit Mimikry und der Rolle von
Oxytocin in der menschlichen Mimikry zu tun. Können Sie
mir erklären, was das ist
?  Ich war daran interessiert, was
menschliche Bindungen unterstützt, also welche
Mechanismen wir haben, die den
Aufbau sozialer Verbindungen und
auch Gruppenbindungen unterstützen, und einer dieser
Mechanismen ist die Nachahmung der Körperbewegungen anderer Menschen
wir
tun das, und wir tun das, ohne zu merken,
dass wir es tun, also könnte es
alles sein, es könnte dein Haar berühren,
es könnte Essen zittern, es könnte sein, du
weißt schon, ich weiß nicht, wir benutzen ein Objekt, das wir
normalerweise tun, ohne es zu merken  dass
wir andere Leute gemacht haben, aber es hat eine
soziale Funktion, also ist das der
interessante Teil, also wer auch immer nachahmt
und wer auch immer nachgeahmt wird, sie fühlen
sich der anderen Person nahe und sie haben das Gefühl,
dass es eine subjektive Verbindung gibt
, die über diese Art von reiner Körperähnlichkeit hinausgeht
zwischen den beiden Leuten, also
habe ich es immer sehr genossen, das zu studieren,
und dann interessierten wir uns dafür,
was die Art von Mimikry der hormonellen
Unterstützung wäre, mhm und besonders
emotionale Mimikry, die eine ganz
besondere Art der Mimikry ist, denn
offensichtlich hat ein Gesichtsausdruck viel mehr Bedeutung
als Sie wissen,
Essensshakes, die auch
bedeutungsvoll sein könnten, je nachdem, wie Sie den
Kontext kennen, aber normalerweise würden Emotionen
mit viel einhergehen  zu bedeuten, dass du bereit bist,
jemanden anzulächeln oder nicht
anzulächeln, ein Lächeln könnte
viel bedeuten oder Traurigkeit ausdrücken, wenn
jemand auch traurig ist, also oh, das teilt
der anderen Person mit, dass du eine Bindung hast,
die Nachahmung, also ja, so sieht dieses Projekt
aus  über die Rolle von Oxytocin, einem
Hormon, das an
sozialen Funktionen beteiligt ist, und wir wollten sehen,
ob Oxytocin auch
Mimik oder Gesichtsausdrücke unterstützt
In Form eines Sprays bekam
die andere Gruppe ein Placebo und
dann wurden ihnen einige
Gesichtsausdrücke präsentiert und sie wussten nicht,
dass wir Mesurin sind  g ihre Reaktionen auf
diese Ausdrücke, die sie dachten, es wäre eine
Gesichtserkennungsaufgabe. Ja, also, was
würde passieren, wenn sie, wenn Oxytocin
Oxytocin ist, wirklich eine Wirkung hat, was
passieren würde, wie, was könnten wir
jetzt tun
?  Oxytocin und dann bin ich sozialer,
würde das helfen,
offensichtlich sind diese Effekte komplex, also
würde ich das nicht so einfach sagen,
mm-hmm, aber es unterstützt definitiv die
Idee, dass Oxytocin eine soziale Rolle spielt,
also wenn sie es nicht war
zum Beispiel bei der Geburt von Kindern und beim
Geschlechtsverkehr, also Dinge, die
für die menschliche Sozialität ziemlich grundlegend sind, und dann
gibt es Arbeiten, die zeigen, dass
Oxytocin bei komplexeren Formen der
Sozialität eine Rolle spielt, also zum Beispiel bei romantischen
Partnern, die
am Anfang einen hohen Oxytocinspiegel haben  In ihrer
Beziehung ist es wahrscheinlicher, dass
sie sechs Monate später wieder zusammen sind, was sehr
interessant ist, also scheint es, als würde es
ziemlich komplexe Formen der Bindung unterstützen, also denke ich,
dass die Mimikry r ist  Die Ergebnisse sind
interessant, nur weil sie
diese Reaktion auf niedrigerem Niveau zeigen, weil die
Nachahmung von Gesichtsausdrücken
etwas ist, das fast automatisch ist, sodass
Sie nicht wirklich darüber nachdenken, als ob
Sie nicht wüssten, dass Sie dafür bewertet
werden, also zeigt es sich  Dass, wenn das so geht
, dass komplexere
Auswirkungen diesen einfacheren Effekt in
Bezug auf die Körpermimikry durchlaufen könnten, ist wirklich lustig,
denn während Sie sprechen, denke ich immer,
dass wir
genau das tun, während wir genau das
tun  interview diese
machende sache ja es ist so lustig sobald
du von der forschung
weißt dann wirst du sehr also weißt du wenn du in einer bar bist
kannst du immer versuchen mädchen nachzuahmen dich
interessiert ihre stimme du
interessierst dich ja und schau ob  es funktioniert Ich
denke, wenn die andere Person merkt, dann
funktioniert es wahrscheinlich nicht, was ist
das Ziel Ihrer Forschung, gibt es so
etwas wie Sie
damit zusteuern? Ja, ich glaube, ich meine, es gibt
nur ein epidemisches Ziel, denke ich, welches  ist,
bessere Mechanismen zu verstehen,
die Pro-Sozialität unterstützen, die menschliche
Verbindungen unterstützen, und ich denke, ich meine,
sobald wir diese Mechanismen verstehen
, können wir offensichtlich Menschen helfen, die
mit dieser Art von Aktivitäten zu kämpfen haben, ja, diese Art von
Aktivitäten könnte so offensichtlich
verwendet werden  ein größeres Gut,
aber ich denke, ja, meine
Motivation, in dieses Feld zu gehen, war eher
aus Neugier, wirklich okay, ja, perfekt,
und haben Sie einen Tipp für uns,
weil vielleicht ein sozialer Tipp, vielleicht ja,
etwas, das wir mit Ihnen tun könnten,
wie Sie  du recherchierst dazu
hast du was zum rausholen und
sagst dann hey das ist die kernaussage und ich
habe einen tipp für dich ist vielleicht gibt es
was wenn nicht dann musst du natürlich
nicht antworten ja ich denke in
diesem bereich der nachahmung  und
Synchronizität, das ist etwas anderes
, was ich studiert habe, ist wie tatsächliche
freiwillige Synchronität, also Leute, die zusammen rudern
oder zusammen singen,
und das ist ein bisschen ein anderer
Prozess, aber immer noch ziemlich neu  verbunden mit der
unbewussten Nachahmung, und wir finden, dass dies
sehr wirkungsvolle Wege sind,
Menschen zusammenzubringen, also denke ich, ich meine das als
Tipp, wenn Sie ein Lehrer sind oder
jemand, der mit Gruppen von
Menschen arbeitet, könnte das sehr hilfreich sein  Eine
wirkungsvolle Art, Menschen dazu zu bringen, als
Team zusammenzuarbeiten, könnte auch für alle möglichen
negativen Zwecke verwendet werden, also denke ich,
dass sich nur die Auswirkungen der Tatsache bewusst zu machen
, dass Sie wissen, dass die Synchronisation mit
jemand anderem nur die Synchronisation Ihrer
Körperbewegungen tatsächlich bewirken könnte  Sie
spüren eine engere Verbindung und kooperieren
mehr, könnten Sie aber auch
gehorsamer machen und vielleicht auf eine Weise, die Sie
vielleicht nicht sein möchten, und daher denke ich, dass
dies mein Tipp wäre, sich dieser Mechanismen bewusst zu sein
und dann darüber nachzudenken,
wie wir  können sie in der Praxis verwenden ja
okay vielen Dank vielen Dank vielen
Dank ja bis zu einer nächsten Folge
in Fillercast die anderen Videos zum
Moralpsychologie-Workshop hatten wir
gestern oder in der Beschreibung
Schaut mal rein und abonniert wenn es euch gefallen hat tschüss